make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this
is rob and we are back with another
installment of how to help superheroes
finish with all their living
uh in this one we're focusing on super
villains
i feel like that should be the new title
right how to help superheroes finish
with all their living i think it'd be an
amazing title it'd be funny
it'd be hilarious mostly because i came
up with it
but uh in this video we're tackling one
of the biggest bad guys in the dc
universe
dark side but before we get into how to
kill darkseid we'll go over his origin
and powers to see why killing him is
actually so difficult
so darkseid was created by jack kirby
and made his first cameo appearance in
superman's pal jimmy ulsa number 134
back in 1970 before making his first
full appearance in forever people number
one
in 1971 so dark side's origin has
undergone some
changes over the years and so i'll try
to briefly go over both versions and
then we'll move on to darkseid's powers
so in his original origin he was simply
known as prince uxas and he was the son
of king yuka khan
and queen hegra of apocalypse and so
darkseid's brother drax ends up stealing
the omega force an extremely powerful
energy source from his father and uxas
kills drax but his exposure to the omega
force transforms him into dark side he
then kills his mother
and takes over the throne of apocalypse
which he ruled as a brutal tyrant and
became one of the most feared villains
in the entirety of the dc universe now
when dc rebooted their continuity in
2011 with the new 52
dark side's origin changed drastically
instead of being a prince
uxas was born a poor farmer tired of
constantly toiling just to survive
eukstas decides that the gods have
abandoned ordinary people
and sets his sights on revenge and so
while the gods slept uke's climbs the
mountain where they live and whispers
doubts into their ears prompting them to
go to war with one another and once
they're weakened from battle
uxas kills them steals their power and
transforms his home world
into apocalypse and so in terms of power
darkseid is incredibly powerful due to
his new god physiology which also makes
him immortal so once again we're tasked
with killing
an immortal being his strength is nearly
immeasurable and he's been able to throw
punches that dealt damage to some of
dc's strongest characters
most notably superman but also captain
adam and even eclipso who rivals the
spectre in terms of power
darkseid's durability is also at a
ridiculous level
and he survived an explosion that was
said to be able to destroy
all of reality now darkseid's primary
offensive weapon is his ability to wield
the omega effect which he most often
uses in the form of omega beams usually
to devastating effects but the omega
beams
are inescapable and potent enough not
only to deal substantial damage to
superman but even
harmed the spectre darkseid can also use
the omega effect to create the omega
sanction which traps his opponents in an
endless stream of successively worse
lies constantly dying and being reborn
into more miserable circumstances for
all of eternity it's pretty brutal stuff
but that's just how a guy like darkseid
gets his kicks i suppose but he also
possesses
vast telepathic ability telekinesis
matter manipulation and possesses
incredible intelligence and so like i
said one of the most powerful villains
in all of dc
comics which is why we have our work cut
out for us and finding a way to kill him
and so to that end i always think the
best way to approach developing our
strategy in these videos is to look for
some sort of weakness that we can use to
our advantage
and so does this effectively immortal
nearly all powerful villain
have any weaknesses is it even possible
to kill him the answer is yes
in fact he has died multiple times
throughout his history one of these
instances that we can look to for
inspiration occurred during final crisis
when batman
shot darkseid with a bullet made of a
substance called radeon
now while we don't really know much
about radeon in terms of where it came
from or what its properties are
one thing we do know is that it is
harmful to the new gods and can be
lethal in certain circumstances
for instance the new god orion who's
actually the biological son of dark side
was killed by a bullet
made of radeon and later batman would
hit darkseid with the same bullet that
nearly killed him and so shortly after
he's mortally wounded by the bullet
darkseid is visited by the black racer
who functions as the grim reaper of the
new gods showing up when they die to
collect their souls now originally the
black racer was chasing barry allen and
wally west to collect them but they
redirect his attention to darkseid and
he completes the job of killing him and
so just from this one instance we can
see
two possible ways to take dark side out
in the form of radeon
as well as the black racer and while
these two things worked in tandem to
kill dark side of final crisis
i think that either one of them on their
own would be sufficient to get the job
done
in fact the black racer has taken out
darkseid more than once and brought
about his death again
in the dark side war after the
anti-monitor fused the black racer
together with the flash
using the anti-life equation and sends
him after darkseid now darkseid is then
killed by the black racer along with the
anti-monitor's blast and so once again
more than one factor at work here but we
can see the dark side is definitely
killable now speaking of the anti-life
equation while radeon is
probably the simplest way to kill
darkseid i think the most poetic way
would be to use the object of darkseid's
obsession
the anti-life equation itself now the
energy life equation is a formula that
can be used to control the minds of
others and functions basically as proof
that life itself
is futile in the cosmic odyssey
storyline written by jim starlin four
aspects of the anti-life equation
infiltrate the dc universe
and dark side in many of dc's heroes
actually work together to retrieve these
aspects
because they threaten the very existence
of the galaxy in all reality itself now
while darkseid is still
intent on capturing the anti-life
equation he soon realizes that it's more
powerful than he thought
and it could definitely kill him and so
i think the coolest way to kill darkseid
would be to use the one thing that he's
tried to harness for most of his
existence the anti-life equation
granted this would probably be
challenging to acquire but it would be
my preferred method of taking him out as
i think it would just be some great
poetic justice for him to meet his own
end and this is really probably the best
instance that we see of darkseid
being killed by the anti-life equation
as he was also killed by his daughter
grail
using the equation after she'd
resurrected him in the form of a child
following his aforementioned death at
the hands of the anti-monitor in black
racer
grail however would resurrect her father
once again in the form of an infant that
she intended to raise
which leads us to a real problem which
is whatever means are used to kill
darkseid he always seems to come back at
some point so really
the only way we can prevent this from
happening is to eliminate fan interest
in the character
because as long as stories were darkside
is the villain sell books he's not going
to stay dead permanently
basically like batman i know that's a
little meta and not usually what we do
in this series but it's the truth in
this case darkseid has died
multiple times and each time he comes
back because he's just one of the most
compelling villains in dc comics killing
darkseid is almost like killing the
joker or killing batman
sure you could do it but you know he's
always going to come back due to his
popularity
even if we found a way to throw him into
the anti-matter universe or trap him in
the source wall to prevent his
resurrection the writers at dc would
eventually find a way to bring him back
just as they always do but i think
despite the fact that he'll inevitably
return
we have at least done our jobs in
finding ways that he can be killed
albeit temporarily but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an
end uh if you are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
hey
[Music]
we all come from somewhere
[Music]
a place with a name
[Music]
we can make it happen
turn things around
let's be the change we want to see
[Music]
[Music]
on a moving train
in this we're all the same
with